字幕: Hiroko Kawano
校正: Riaki Poništ
こんにちは 今泉奏です
２年前 私はアフリカを陸路で一周しました
それもトラック移動とキャンプ生活の旅です
陸路での旅は いつもは愉しいものです
現地を自分の足で歩き
その地域に住む人と同じ目線で
世界を眺めることができるからです
私が旅したアフリカの国は28ヶ国
アフリカにある国のおよそ半分です
およそ10ヶ月をかけて旅をしたのですが
それでも わずか半分の国しか
旅することができませんでした
旅のルートは
ジブラルタル海峡から モロッコに渡り
今度はケープタウンへ南下します
今度は ケープタウンから
ずーっと北に上がっていき
エジプトのカイロがゴールです
私はこの旅の記録を
『アフリカさるく紀行』という
ブログにまとめることにしました
「さるく」とは
私の地元 長崎の方言で
「歩いて回る」という意味です
英語で言うと「walking around」
という訳を当てたいところですが
それとは ちょっと異なります
もっと キョロキョロしながら歩いて回る —
どちらかというと「wandering」
に近い感覚でしょうか
さて 今日は 私が アフリカを
「さるいてみえた グラデーション」
についてのお話をしたいと思います
その前に 私がなぜまず
アフリカに興味を持ったのかについて
話さなければなりません
「なんでアフリカなんか勉強してるの？」
「なんでアフリカのこと やってんの？」って
今まで幾度となく聞かれてきました
この質問をされる度に
私はいつも答えに窮してしまうのですが
今日は遠い記憶をたどって
その答えを少しだけ見つけてきました
１つはこれ
私が小学生の頃
日本と韓国でW杯がありました
当時 社会科の授業でその出場国について
調べる授業があったのです
私のクラスメートたちは
イタリアやイングランド
ドイツやブラジルといった
サッカーの有名国について調べていました
ですが 私はなぜかこの国
カメルーンについて調べていたのです
今となっては 全く思い出せないのですが
ただ 他の人と少しだけ
違うことをしたかったのだと思います
それから 中学校に進学すると
地元ホークスの大ファンだった私は
プロ野球に熱中していました
特にその当時活躍していた
バルデスやズレーターといった
黒人選手に憧れることになります
それから 高校に進学すると
陸上競技部に所属していたこともあり
当時活躍していた
ケニア人ランナーたちに憧れました
そこで １冊の本と出会うことになります
『ケニア！彼らはなぜ速いのか』
という本です
この本には ケニア人ランナーの
身体的特徴だけでなく
彼らが生み出される社会的背景
経済的な面 そして歴史的な面まで
深く網羅されていました
この本から私は
黒人選手やケニア人ランナー
といったスポーツ選手だけではなく
そこから広くアフリカを
知りたいと思うようになりました
これが 高校１年生の時です
その時 すぐに私はスワヒリ語専攻に
入学しようということを決めました
そしてその時 もう一つのものと
出会うことになります
それが オーバーランドでの旅です
なぜ オーバーランドか？
当時テレビ番組でやっていたからです
あるテレビ番組で
カイロからケープタウンまで
アフリカを114日間で縦断する
オーバーランドの旅についての
特集をやっていました
私はこれを見て 俄然 興味が湧きました
特に キャンプしながらゆっくりとゆっくりと
旅していくスタイルに憧れたのです
よくよく調べてみると
これ アフリカ縦断だけではなく
アフリカ一周の旅もあるということで
私はこれに参加しようということも決めました
こうした オーバーランドですが
もう少し私の中には理由があります
１つは 私がアフリカのジェネラリストに
なりたいということでした
１つの特定の地域の専門になるのではなく
アフリカ大陸をひろく知っている
物知りになりたかったんです
そのためには アフリカの
１つの国にずっといるだけではなく
ひろく ゆっくりと自分の目で
アフリカを見て周る必要がありました
もう１つは 私の地元の方言
「さるく」にも代表されるように
自分の足で見て回りたいと思ったからです
それがこちら「足で学ぶ」という理由です
この２つのことができる
それが オーバーランドの旅でした
さて そのオーバーランドの旅に出るのに
２つの準備がまた必要でした
１つは 私は学生です
お金がないんです
だからお金を集めなければなりません
もちろん アルバイトもしましたが もう１つ
クラウドファンディングをやりました
クラウドファンディングは
最近インターネット上で
お金を集める方法として注目されています
そして このクラウドファンディングを
やるに当たって必要だったのが
私の旅のテーマを決めることです
私は 旅のテーマを自分の専門でもある
「アフリカの歴史」にしました
じゃあ 具体的に何をしたかというと
旅した各国で その地の教科書を
集めていったんです
特に 歴史の教科書 社会科の教科書
を中心に集めました
それから その各地に住んでいる人にとって
「歴史とは何ですか？」や
「あなたの持っている歴史観は何ですか？」
のような質問をたくさんしました
そして 教科書と現地の人の聞き取りから
アフリカについての歴史を学びました
さあ みなさんのアフリカの
イメージはどうでしょうか？
私はこの旅に出る前
既にアフリカについて学んでいたので
ある程度の知識は自分でもあった
という風に思っています
しかし 一般的にアフリカって
均一的と思われていないでしょうか？
同じような人が住んでいて
同じようなものを食べて
そして 気候も同じように暑い
でも 実際それは違います
私が旅したスーダンは
53℃を超える灼熱でした
一方 モロッコの高山地帯や
アフリカの最高峰タンザニアの
キリマンジャロの山頂まで登ってみると
氷点下です
この気温差を均一的と表現できるでしょうか？
それは違います
アフリカは多様性があるところだ
という風に言われるのです
アフリカを少しでもかじったことがある人
もしくは アフリカ大陸を旅したことがある人
そういう人は これに
とても共感できると思います
但し 私はこれにもう１つ加えたい
単に多様性でバラバラで
色んなものがあるだけではなく
そこに 「グラデーション」があるんです
単に違うだけじゃない 同じところもある
それが ゆっくりとゆっくりと変わってゆく
それが見えるのが私の旅でした
その１つ 青色の町
モロッコのシャウエンです
この中央の家は モロッコの
シャウエンの１つの街角です
私は そこで出会ったベルベル人の
男性にこう言われました
「この水色 この青色は
ベルベル人の信仰の対象であって
水の青であり 空の青なんだよ」 と
こうした ベルベル人の村 シャウエンの町
こちらは エジブトの町です
モロッコとエジプト
それはサハラ砂漠を介して
遠く離れていますが
同じような水色が使われているのです
ちなみにこちらは
ベルベル人ではなくヌビア人の家です
彼らが話す言語 そして文化
しゃべっている言葉
もしくは食べているもの
っていうのは 若干違うのですが
それでもこの青い色というのは
共通した文化として残っているんです
さあ こうしたグラデーションは
なんでできるんでしょうか？
その正体は一体全体 なんなんでしょうか？
私はもう少し考えてみることにしました
その１つがこちら
大型の家畜がいないことです
サハラ砂漠より南には熱帯病があり
大型の家畜を飼育するのが困難です
例えば ラクダ
ラクダは サハラ砂漠では
もちろん飼育ができますが
サハラ砂漠以南になると 熱帯病で飼育が困難
また 長距離移動に適した馬も飼育が困難です
それに加えて 大型の船は アフリカ大陸では
なかなかできてきませんでした
その代わり
こうした ダウ船というような
帆船が長らく使われてきました
こうした船で１ヶ月や２ヶ月をかけて
東アフリカからインド洋へと
旅立って行ったのです
さあ こうして
大きい船が作られなかったり
もしくは 大型の家畜が使われないと
どうなるか？
人が歩いて移動して
社会が作られてゆくのです
もちろん 牛や驢馬や羊
といった家畜は飼育できます
但し それらの家畜は
長距離移動には適さないのです
さあ こうやって僕が同じスピードで
文化が作られたようなスピードで
さるいてみたからこそ分かった
エピソードを少し紹介したいと思います
それが 「食べて感じたグラデーション」です
こちら 真ん中の写真は
ガーナの「フフ」という料理です
この白色のビニル袋に入っているのが
「フフ」という主食になります
こちらは ヤム芋やキャッサバを粉末にして
そして 沸騰したお湯で溶いて練ったものです
これをこんなシチューなんかに
つけて食べることがあります
ちなみに こちら側は
南アフリカの「パップ」という食べ物です
同じように白色です
但し 原料が違います —
こちらはトウモロコシです
味も少し違って
こちらの「フフ」よりは
もっと味がある感じ
そして ちょっとだけザラザラしています
さらに こちら — また見た目は同じです
こちらは トウモロコシからできています
南アフリカの「パップ」と同じです
但し こちらの方がより淡白な味わいです
何となく自分の感覚としては
鹿児島の「かるかん」に
似たような感じがします
まあ こうした 似たような
食べ物があるんですけど
味も違うんですよね
そして その発酵のさせ方
なんかも違ったりして
中には こういう
同じような粉を練ったものでも
酸っぱいものとかもあったりします
これが アフリカの面白さです
同じようなものを使っているように見えても
そこにグラデーションがあるんです
さて キャンプをしたことがある人なら
誰でもお分かりだと思います
その地にキャンプをしたからこそ
地面の凹凸が分かるんです
もしくは 風の音が分かるんです
もしくは 木の匂いや 地を這う生き物を
見つけることができるんです
こうして キャンプして旅しながら感じた
グラデーションについて
今度はお話したいと思います
その１つがこちら
ケニアからエチオピアへと
ずーっと北上していった時の
ハイライトです
まず ケニアからエチオピアへ
少しだけ旅をしていくと
まだまだ緑が広がったところが見えてきます
まだ ここに至る前の段階です
そこでは まだ農耕が行われています
それよりも さらに北にいくと
だんだんだんだん
牛や山羊の大量の群れを
見つけることができます
100頭や200頭単位で飼育してるのです
それから更に北上して行くと
また乾燥してきます
そうすると 今度はこちら —
ラクダの群れに出会うことになります
ラクダの群れに出会った時は壮観でした
なぜなら 牛というのは —
あまり見たことがある人も
いないかも知れませんが —
人間と同じくらいの高さです
但し ラクダとなると
完全に見上げてしまいます
それぐらい大きなラクダの群れ
とっても迫力があります
そこから 更に北上して行きます
そうするとどうなるか？
もう一度 緑が増えてくるんです
そしてまた 牛の群れに出会うことになります
但し 先ほどまでの牛の群れとは異なります
先ほどは 100頭単位での牛の群れでした
今度は 10頭ぐらいです
同じものを飼育していても その飼育方法が
だんだんだんだん
旅するに当たって変わってくるんです
こうした家畜のグラデーションや
自然のグラデーションも
アフリカを旅する面白さです
さて 私はみなさんにもこうした
グラデーションを感じて欲しいのですが
ちょっとアフリカに行くのは
困難だという人が多いと思います
もちろん 私の希望としては
みなさんにアフリカに行って欲しいです
ただ そういう訳にも行かないので
旅をしてみてください
日本国内でも良いんです
特に田舎の方が良いと思いますね
で 田舎を旅して その土地に
暮らしている人に話を聞いてください
単なる世間話から始まっても良いです
でも ちょっとだけ深い話を
聞こうとしてください
「そこにある歴史って何ですか？」とか
「ここ独特の食べ物とか
ここ独特の文化って何ですか？」って
ちょっと聞いてみてください
で それだけで終わりじゃないんです
それから ちょっとだけ足を伸ばして
隣町へ行ってみてください
また同じことをしてください
そうすると そこに少しグラデーションを
感じることができると思います
さあ それさえも億劫だという人が
いるかも知れません
そういう人は もうしょうががありません
今度は基礎工学部と理学部の
間に立ってみてください
（笑）
もしくは 文学部や経済学部の間
石橋か蛍池の間でもどちらでも良いです
そこに立ってみるとですね
そこに行き交う人がいるので
必ずグラデーションが見て取れるんです
きっと 理学部と基礎工学部にいる人の
顔は違うと思います
語っていることも違うと思います
その違いに耳を澄ませてください
目を凝らしてください
遠いアフリカでも
もっと近い自分の身の回りの世界でも
グラデーションを見つけられるかどうかは
全てあなた次第です
ありがとうございました
（拍手）